今天我們來聊一個很有意思的現象。你可能沒想到，在中國，現在連律師、建築師、工程師這些高學歷的專業人士，都開始做起了AI模型的訓練零工。
等等，這些人不是應該在辦公室，做著高薪的工作嗎？怎麼會去做零工？這聽起來有點出乎意料，甚至是跟一般想法不同吧。
其實這背後的原因，就是中國現在經濟下行。原文提到，像一位在深圳的建築師 Cuicui，她設計過體育場、學校、醫院，但過去五年，政府基礎設施支出減少，她的收入直接減半了。
收入減半？那確實是很嚴重的打擊。但專業人士去訓練AI，這具體是做什麼？難道是教AI畫設計圖嗎？這模式撐得久嗎？成本划算嗎？
沒錯，就是教AI。原文說，Cuicui 下班後會在一個叫做 TalentsAI 的平台上，一步一步地教AI模型怎麼寫建築提案，或者做盈利分析。她說就像教小孩一樣，每個任務都來自她實際的工作。
嗯… 這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字。訓練一項任務，通常需要幾個小時，可以賺100到500人民幣，大概是15到74美元。這跟他們以前的收入比，算高嗎？
當然不算高，這些零工的薪資比美國的同行低。但對他們來說，面對艱難的就業市場和AI帶來的衝擊，這是一個賺錢的方法。原文裡一位有碩士學位的法律顧問就說：「如果我不把我的知識傳給AI，其他人也會做。」
這個說法很有意思。所以對創業者或主管來說，這提供了什麼啟發？是不是說，以後可以不用請全職員工，直接找這些高技能的零工來訓練AI？
我覺得可以這麼看。中國國家數據管理局在六月就鼓勵更多行業專家深入數據標註工作，提升AI訓練數據的「知識密度」。這表示企業可以活用這些高技能零工來降低成本、提升AI開發效率。像阿里巴巴的 Siriser 平台，還有字節跳動的 Xpert，都已經在招募老師、工程師、甚至音樂作曲家來做AI訓練師。
招募這麼多不同領域的專家，那這些AI訓練會不會變成越來越難？因為AI學習的速度很快。
確實會。原文提到，訓練師要設計AI目前還不能獨立解決的任務，隨著AI越來越聰明，這點會變得越來越困難。而且，零工訓練師也抱怨他們的產出有時會被品控團隊拒絕，那表示他們幾個小時的努力就白費了。
聽起來這工作也並非一帆風順。那對一般上班族來說，我們可以從這個概念帶入自己的工作或生活嗎？
其實，這好像也提醒了我們，即使是專業技能，在面對新的技術變革時，也要思考如何找到新的變現方式，或者說，學習如何把自己的「知識」商品化，不只給公司用，也可以用在其他地方。